a team is probably best model as a kind
it's a concrete structure that can have
many entities a game is also best
modeled as a kind for the same reasons
as for team the winning team is probably
best modelled as an entity but this
answer is not so straightforward it
could for example be a property value in
an entity a player is probably best
modeled as a kind for the same reasons
as team and gain and the player name
sounds like it's modeled through a
property value I hope you did well on
the quiz alright that's an introduction
to data store now it's about time to
check out some code don't you think
let's do that good luck